では よろしくお願いします
今日はススキですか 今日はススキですが
何のススキでしょうかとは
うーん 少々つなげることはちょこっと難しいんですけども
ものすごい難しいんですな
今は  いわゆるあの まあ正見
正見というサマーディティについて
お釈迦様の微妙な解説になっています
この前ワンセットを説明しました
このセットセットで説明するんですね
この前説明したのは サマーディティ
正見が育てようとする精進努力は正精進であると
それから正見で邪見をなくすんですね
なぜ正見生まれてくるのかというと
邪見をなくすためなんです
そこで仏教でいう正見って何なのかとこの前説明しましたね
正見邪見というのは 仏教は正見で他宗教は邪見というふうな
まあこれだらしない意味じゃないんです
仏教では正見邪見というのは
ものすごい哲学的に ものすごい高度な知識で
真理 知識 そういう世界から考えているんです
ですから 明らかに哲学の管轄なんですね
認識とは何ぞやというね
人の認識は可能でしょうかとかね
そういう管轄に入る正見邪見なんです
ただ 汝は何を信仰しているのかという話じゃないんです
ですから 正見が 2種類がありまして
一つは俗世間的な正見
それはわかりやすく言えば因果法則を認めること
それが正見なんですよ
なぜならば 世の中はどう見たっても因果法則でしょうに
そこで因果法則は断固と否定する人々はいますよ
しかし 彼らが因果法則を断固と否定するために因果法則を使っているんだから
話にならない そこで あの
普通我々の常識の世界で
宗教と関係ない常識の世界で
我々はできるだけ因果法則に則って物事を考えたり
あの いろいろなことをやったりはする
そうでなきゃ成り立ちませんよ
何一つも 例えば 誰かの会社が
あの 何て言いますか インサイダー取引しましたよという
ただ単に金持ちすごい
あんたインサイダー取引してたでしょ
逮捕やと言って それは成り立たないでしょうね
で そうするともういろんな証拠を調べて調べて
こういうことで こういうことで
こういうことで あんたやったんだから
あんたはインサイダー取引やったことになりますと
そこは因果法則なんですね
だから今 インサイダー取引で逮捕されている方にしたっても
代表してお金払ってますから
あなた逮捕されてくださいと言ったって
それは決して成り立ちませんよ
世の中では ですから この
いつでも因果法則っていうのは必要なことで
必要なことじゃないんですよ
因果法則が事実なんです
これはもうどうにもならないことで
世の中は因縁によって変化していく
人にいきなり泥棒やと言っちゃうと
それは侮辱なんですね
なぜならば根拠がないんだから
しかし 泥棒だったらどうしますか
侮辱じゃないでしょ それで泥棒っていうのは
他人のものを盗ること
ある人は他人のものを盗ったから泥棒ということになる
泥棒に泥棒言うことは侮辱じゃないんです
だけで我々の好き勝手にあんたはどれほどあんたは嘘つきやとか言うことはできないでしょうに
世の中でそう言わないでしょうに
人にあんた嘘つきやとうろぎり者やと怒鳴る時でも
何かの証拠があって怒鳴ってるでしょうに
それが俗世間にある明確な因果法則なんですよ
それで我々世の中で信頼されてもらうために
それから自分でもしっかりと騙されないでしっかりと生きているためには
いつでも因果法則を大事にせなくちゃいけない
あんまり情報を知らないことは
そこは気をつけた方がいい
ペラペラ喋るんじゃなくて
しっかり情報を知っている場合でも
まあこれこれぐらい情報がございまして
だったらこれぐらいの結論に至れるんじゃないかなというふうに喋る人は
すごく真理を守っているというんですね
なぜならば 因果法則にのっとって考えたり行動したりする
で 我々 私のお腹が空いたら
風邪薬飲んでも治らないでしょうに
なぜならば因果法則じゃないでしょ
お腹が壊してるならば胃薬飲むんですよ
胃薬はお腹の調子を改良するためにできているものです
それに風邪薬を飲んだったら
もう決して治るはずがないんです
だから 存在の中に明らかにあるのは因果法則なんです
一切の現象が因果法則に成り立つのだよというのを
ブッダの考え方です そこまではみんなにわからないんだから
まあ大体のところで因果法則を認めなさい
でなきゃもう邪見だよと
だから 母に母という存在は存在しませんとかね
来世なんかはあるわけじゃないんだとかね
修行なんかは嘘インチキやと
そんな修行したっても
超越した境地に成り立ちませんよと
人に寄付したっても何の意味もないんだよとか
そこで道徳的な世界をお釈迦様がハイライトしておくんです
お釈迦様ももうご飯食べた人は籾を蒔きなさいとかね
トウモロコシを蒔くなかれという必要ないでしょうに
それぐらいのこと知ってますからね
トウモロコシの種蒔いて人はトウモロコシ食べる羽目になっちゃうし
籾を蒔いた人はご飯を食べることになるし
だからそういう俗世間の車はどうやって作れましょうかとかね
飛行機はどういうふうな法則で飛ばされますかとか
そんなのはもう誰でも知ってることだから
ブッダには興味がない
だから誰にも発見できないのは
この心の法則で 心の働きで
道徳の世界ですね だからこの俗世間の邪見は10項目ありますね
その場合は確実に精神的なことを言っているんです
だから人にものをあげたっても何の意味もない
ただ 物質移動だけじゃないでしょうね
そこで働きありますね
私はものを持っているという心の気持ち
はい それ与えますよという心の気持ち
だから随分違う気持ちが生まれるんですね
それによって結果があるんだと
それで正見が 2種類ありまして
2番目はブッダが語る
この超越した出世間的なレベルの正見なんですね
これは教説 説明しておいておきます
仏教でいう正しい いわゆる厳密な極限的な正見というのは
修行してあらゆる概念
あらゆるものをもう破って破って破って
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で言っていて
それで一切概念消えたところで
この概念を作りたがる気持ちもなくなって
もうあるのはこれだけでしょうと
とわかったところで 見解何一つも生まれないというすごいエネルギーが生まれてくるんですね
それは智慧というんですね
そこはそこら中誰にもあるわけじゃないんです
それはもう頑張って育てないといけないことで
だから そのためには 俗世間のレベルで正見もなければもう話にはなりません
まず 俗世間のレベルで正見がある人は
やっぱりこれって厄介なものやとわかっているでしょうしね
それからどんどん頑張って心を清らかにするのはできます
それは正見を育てようと邪見をなくそうとする精進
努力が正精進になって
それで正見で邪見なくすでしょうに
邪見をなくすために気づき
サティが必要なんですね
だって知ることは必要ですからね
気づいたらこれがもう邪見であると気づいたらこれが正見であると発見します
はっきりしますから だから気づき
サンマサティですね 正念正念ですね
これも必要なんです だから
この 3つがいつでもお互いに時点しているんだと
何を時点しているのかというと
正見を好転しているんですね
だからわからないところは
正見がどうやって正見を好転しているのかということなんです
だから 間違いは好転という単語にある意味
好転では物質的なことだからね
だから正見が中心になって
正見を支えてくれて 追っかけてきて追っかけてきて
正見のレベルを向上するのは正念と正精進とまた正見なんです
だから これグラフにも書けない
イラストも描けない   なんか変な関係なんですね
グラフに書けならば こうやって横から縦になっている棒で正見と書いて
下で半径で正念と正精進を書かなきゃいけない
それがそうやって回っていくとどんどん上がっていくんだと
物理的にそういうグラフしか書けない
そうやって回せば回すほど上がるでしょう
あのバネみたいなね ネジとかだったらね
例えば 3つのあれ 何て言います？グルーヴは
えっ？ノリ  3つのノリがあるだったら
それは上は正見で正精進
下一番下のあれ グループグルーヴは正念で
それで回すとどんどん上上上へ行ってしまうという
で この 3セットのからくりで他も説明していくんです
だから厳密にロジカルなんですよ
論理的なんです だからこの論理はもう人間が使うもうくだらん論理で
随分難しいんだからね
だから他の人々は仏教は非論理的やと言うかもしれませんだけど
笑いしかないんです 今日のセクション
どこでしたっけ？今日は
73ページの下段です
73 72で終わっちゃったんですね
本当は72のやったっけ？ 2つ
一つしかやらないですね
サンマディッティ  サンマディッティで終わりましたね
ですから 72ページの一番下の段落
タトラビッカウェーサンマディッティプッバンガマホーティカタンチャビッカウェーサンマディッティプッバンガマホーティミッチャーサンカッパングミッチャーサン
カッポーティパジャナーティサンマサンカッッパングサンマサンカッポーティパジャナーティサッスホーティサンマディッテ
ィ それでまたサンマディッティに新しい定義が入ります
もうこの前の定義と違って
で 定義が入りませんだけど
サンマーディッティプンバングマホート
いつでもサンマーディッティは先頭だと
正見がすべての良いことの先頭です
先に正見がないと何一つも成り立たないと
良いことなら だから正見っていうのは偉大なる項目なんです
この上のない項目なんです
ます正見があるんだと
次に どうやってますます先頭で正見があるということを言えるのかと
ミッチャーサンカッパミッチャーサンカッポゥティパジャーナティ
サンカッパというのは思惟でしたっけ？考え
え？思惟 で ミッチャー間違っている
邪思惟をはっきりとこれが邪思惟であると知っています
だから知ること だから当たり前
正見になっちゃうんですね
それからサンマーサンカッパ
正思惟 正しい思考 正しい考え方については
これが正しい考え方であるとはっきりとします
で 我々の場合はそれはっきりしないんですね
やっぱり場合によってということを言うでしょうね
この場合によってっていうのは即席の話で
怒るのは良いことですかと
いえ 悪いんですよと 断言的に
いえ まあ場合によって怒った方がいい場合もありますよと言ったりするんですね
ですから まあ観念的に聞いちゃうと答え出ますけど
例えばこの場合はどうでしょうか
この場合はどうでしょうかと言っちゃえば
あ この場合は怒ってるのもしょうがない
というふうに我々は思う
だから 我々は自分の思考について断言的に正と邪に分けることはできないんですよ
すごく灰色にしちゃうんですね
時々欲張ることはいいことでしょうと言ったりして
また悪いことでもあると言ったりする
怒るのは悪いことだと言いながら
またやっぱりいいことやとも言ったりする
だから人間は思考に対して白黒はっきりしないんですね
白黒はっきりする能力がないんです
もう灰色にしておくんですよ
例えば戦争は悪いとどんな日本人も言ってますけど
もし日本国は占領されたら
それだったら冗談じゃない
とことん戦うぞと 片っ端から殺すぞと思っちゃうんですね
だからどちらにしても人殺しなんですけど
はっきりと白黒はしていないんですね
条件によって判断変えちゃうんですね
それは不可能であると
ものの価値はもう変わらない価値があるはずなんです
それが超越した智慧では
まあそれは発見するんだと
ということで 正見ある人は思考に対して明確に白黒はっきりするんです
ちょっとわからないんだけどという状態がないんです
これが悪い これがよろしいとはっきり言えるんです
この判断能力 ビシッと決めることできる
これで並大抵の智慧じゃないんです
並大抵の正見じゃないんです
まあ正見で見解でもよろしいんだからね
正しい見解 あるがままに判断できる
次の問題は では邪思惟は何でしょうか？正思惟は何でしょうかということですね
それ説明に入ります カタモーチャ ビッカウェー サマー サンカッポー サムカーム サンカッポー ヴァーパード サンカッ
ポー ヴィヒンサー サンカッポー アヤン ビッカウェー ミッチャー サンカッポ
ー まあ邪思惟というのは三種類
カーマ サンカッパ 欲の思考
ヴィヤーパーダ サンカッパ
怒りの瞋恚の思考 怒りというより瞋恚なんですね
ヴィヒンサー サンカッポーというのは加害ですかね
与害ですかね 害を与えたいという思考
加害者の思考 加害者でもとっくに害を与えていますけど
ヴィヒンサーだけすごく簡単な単語なんですけど
適切な日本語の単語はないんですよ
害意っていう  害意 害意
それでお釈迦様がこの邪思惟
間違っている思考というところでも
すごい中道というか 中道的なところで話してますよ
思考は だから私が喋る場合
思考はすべてダメというでしょ
ことごとく一切の概念はダメという
そういうふうに言うと困りますよ
人間は思考で生きているんだからね
概念で生きているんだから
人間だけじゃなくて 誰でも概念で生きているんですよ
概念たるものは一切ダメと言っちゃうと
どうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
それは悟りの境地を対象にして
もう瞑想を修行する場合だけに言っている言葉で
瞑想実践する人は まあいかなる概念も敵であって悪魔であると危険視しないと
超越した出世間的な悟りの心が生まれません
甘えちゃうと しかし 完璧に完璧に語る
完全に語るブッダにブッダが
その間違いは起こせません
我々には完璧には語れません
ですから ある環境を作って
その中ででも断言的に語らなくちゃいけないんです
だからお釈迦様はもういつでも八正道の定義はどちらでも当てはまるように完璧に語られていて
思考は三つに分けてます
だから この三つに関係ない思考に困らなくてもいいんです
これ 断言的に黒いんだと
この三つの思考は だから黒いと言ったら
微妙なものでも黒いんです
で 欲に関わる思考 欲っていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身 楽しませることでしょうに
眼耳鼻舌身に刺激を与えることでしょうに
眼耳鼻舌身意も入りますけど
だから肉体に体に刺激を与える
どうやって刺激を与えるのか
そればっかり考えるならば
これはもう 邪思惟なんです
世の中はもうやっぱりずっとそればっかり考えているでしょうね
我々の思考は何かといえば
六根に刺激を与えることなんですね
朝から晩まで考えているのはそういうこと
どうすれば楽しみのかと
人かでは勉強に興っていると
それも楽しいんだからということになるんです
だから普通俗世間ではもう刺激快楽がなければ何もやらない
それで全ての学問も知識も研究も何でもかんでもそういう刺激を与えるということになっているんですね
だから仏教から見れば
社会発展というのはそんなに大した評価できるものじゃない
ただ与える刺激の種類が変わっていくだけで
昔も今も人間に目があるだけで
目に入る刺激が変わったんだ
変えたんだからといって
受ける刺激は目の能力に限ってますからね
だから物質的な発展では発展にはならないんです
見えるものはあれこれと
いくら変わるものを作っても作っても
この目で この眼力で見るしかないでしょうに
目が持っているもう区別作用で
それは変わるわけじゃないんです
で 音もいろいろ開発するんですけど
触るものも開発する 食べるものも開発する
もう何でもかんでも開発するとは言ってますけど
そこであらゆるゲーム開発したり
インターネット開発したり
あれあれっていうのは脳に刺激を与える
ただの刺激 そういうことで
世の中の思考は結局はもうもう邪知には決まってますけど
結局は それ以外何も考えていないんだからね
だから私のことは間違っているわけじゃないんです
でも言い方が間違っているんです
人には反論が作れます
概念なしにどう生きているのかと
たとえ欲がなくても これは絨毯ですと理解していないと
これはテーブルクロスだと誤解したら困るでしょうに
だから概念なしには生きていられないで成り立たないでしょうと言えますから
お釈迦様の場合は反論できない
欲に関わる思考はもう邪知だと
調べてみたら欲に関わる思考しかないかもしれません
そこで 2番目は瞋恚 怒り
憎しみに関わる思考も邪知だと
で さらにもう一つ 害意も邪知であると
害意を与えたくなる だから害意は怒りなんですが
別な枠にしているんですね
何か意味があるかもしれませんだけどね
残念なことに注釈書ではあった方では
そこら辺は研究していないんです
で 瞋恚っていうのは自分で怒りを繁殖することだから
いわゆる妄想の世界なんですね
怒りの思考 あれも悪い
これも悪い これも気に入らん
これあれも気に入らんとかいうふうな感じで
我々はずっと暗い思考
連続させる 回転させる
それはもう暗い思考 回転させることが
まあヴィアーパーで三界になります
じゃあそうそう そこで嫌なものは壊したくなる
害を与えたくなるのはもうヴィアーパーでがちょっと強烈になってるんですよ
しかしただふざけて何でもかんでも壊して楽しむバカもいますよ
例えば風船を割って楽しむとかね
例えばもう風船を持って誰かが誰かの後ろに行って
これもうちょっと針金を刺してもうボンと割ると
これ風船壊してるでしょうね
でも別に怒りじゃないでしょ
この自然破壊のほとんどそうやって欲で片っ端から破壊してやる
金の砂があるのとわかったら
まあ掘って掘って掘っても
山が崩れても もうもう環境がもうどうなっても気にしない
もうやっちゃうというね
破壊していますよ 別に怒りというわけじゃないんですね
そういう差があるんだから
2つにした可能性あります
で それがわかればね 人に迷惑をかけて楽しむとかね
落書き 落書きして楽しむとか
よくあるでしょうに 至る所に日本に行ったらもう落書き
本人たちは喜んでいるでしょうね
それでこれは文化遺産だったらなおさら刺激があって
昼は全くもうもうもう触ることも出して
どこかのね そういうあの文化遺産的に守っている街で
全部もう壊す 落書きで壊されたというね
話 ニュースもありましたし
だからあれも破壊行動といえば破壊行動なんですね
それできれいにペンキ塗ってあるところで
そこをなんとか描いてやったぞと
さらに刺激でしょうね
もう大事に国が守っている文化財に落書きかけちゃうと
刺激が多い もう誰にも見つからないように行かなくちゃいけないし
もういろいろ だから破壊したいという
このテロリストみたいにね
それが明らかに怒りなんですけどね
世の中で怒りがなくても
破壊行動はやってる で
そういうことで そういう思考っていうのは全部邪思惟ですと
本当にそのミス抜けちゃうと何も思考ないんです
だから結局は思考はダメなんですよ
それ以外の思考って何やと
それでカタマーチャ・ビククウェー・サマーサンカッポ
正思惟 正しい思考って何なのかというと
あちらの反対でありますね
しかし その場合は 2つに分ける
正しい思考 思惟は 2つだよと
アッティ・ビッカヴェー・サマーサンカッポ・サーサヴォー・プンヤ・バーギョー・ウパディ・ウェーパクコ
アッティ・ビッカヴェー・サマーサンカッポ・アリヨー・アナーサヴォー・ロークットロ・マッガンゴー
俗世間的で煩悩に関係ある
しかし善良いこと 善の法に入る正思惟がありますと
俗世間的な正思惟もありますと
もう一つは出世間的で解脱の原因になる解脱を司る
正思惟もありますよと
2つだよと それで 1番目は俗世間的なレベルで善行為になる
良いことをすることになる思考もあります
その場合はウパディウェーパック
結果も出てくる 善行為したら善果になるでしょうしね
良い思考が持ってると良い結果が出てくる
それは俗世間のレベル
出世間のレベルは違うんです
それはあとで説明します
まず 1番目 ネッカンマサンカッポ
アヴィャーパーダサンカッポ
アヴィヒンサーサンカッポ
ネッカンマサンカッポ
ネッカンマっていうのは離れる
出て行くという退却するっていう意味なんです
たまにも諦める 厭うという意味でも訳する場合ありますけど
はっきりわからないんですけど
一応退去する 離れる で
欲のカーマサンカッパの場合は
刺激を得る 得る得るという自分の方向に引き寄せる気持ちでしょ
面白いものを見たいんだから
自分の方向に寄ってもらわないと
金は自分の方向に流れてこないと
だから金が欲しいという人がカーマサンカッパでしょ
欲の思考でしょ その場合は
ある物体が自分の方向へ流れてほしい
怒りっていうのは もう自分から判断すると
あんまり方向流れて欲しくないんですね
流れたら困るんですね
だからそれに対して嫌なものだと判断しておくんです
金は入ってきてもいいんだけど
ゴミだけは入ってくるなよと
金の代わりにゴミが来たらすごく腹が立つんです
それで方向性がありますね
それで進んでそのものを潰そうとしちゃうと
害思考にもなります それでネッカンマサンカッパはものすごく違うんです
この自分の方向へ流れてほしいというものは
流れない方がよろしいと思うんです
結構難しいね 理解は ということは
邪思惟しかないということなんです
正思惟したことがないんです
しかし 俗世間では俗世間のレベルで何だ
とか それを味わってみないと
大変なことになります
だから涅槃マサンカッパ味わってみた方がいいんですね
こういうこと 例えばテレビを見て楽しいと
ではいろいろ見て楽しむんじゃなくて
見ないことで安らぎを感じようと
ごちそうを食べて楽しい
それをやめて 肉体を維持するところだけ食べて
この離れることを楽しめよう
災い 煩わしいことから離れることを落ち着きが楽しもう
ということ 例えばもう仕事は苦しいんだけど
では瞑想を楽しもうではない
全部きれいさっぱり忘れて
俗世間との関係 家族との関係
全部忘れて もう切って修行を楽しむ
その場合は その思考がやっと涅槃のサンカッパなんです
だからそこはもう一応経験しておかないと理解もできないんですね
決して頭で理解できる範囲じゃない
もう人間の能力範囲は超えているところから語っている教典なんです
だから研究者やら他の宗教の人には決して理解できない
いくら研究したって知識レベル違います
それで普通は我々にとってはカーマサンカッパはよくわかりやすい
自分の思考そのものだから
涅槃マサンカッパとは何やと
わかりにくいはずなんですね
ですから ものから離れること
刺激から離れることを楽しもうではないかと
例えば 自分住んでいる村でお祭りがあって
みんな大騒ぎして喜んでいるんだと
あれは刺激の楽しみ では
その日私は山に入って
どこかに一日中腰をかけているんだと
その山の中である安らぎを楽しむ
街にあるお祭りがすごく煩わしいと
それは怒りになったらどうにもならないんですよ
すごくニコニコした気分で
で 夜戻ってきたら 上の人々は今日は楽しかったよで
私も今日は思い存分楽しかったよと
お互い様よかったねという感じなんです
で 家族はみんなお祭りに行って
朝から晩まで遊んで遊んで
もう楽しむ むちゃくちゃ楽しんで
夜家に戻る 森に行った自分も
夜暗くなってくると家に戻ると
それでお父さん来なかったんだけど
ほんとすごい楽しかったよと
あ そうですか よかったよかった
私も今日は本当にすごく楽しかったよと
しかし そこでわかるでしょ
そのケースで一人がカーマサンカッパで喜んでいて
もう一人が涅槃マサンカッパで喜んでいて
誰の方が幸福になっているのかと
祭り朝から晩まで祭りにふざけた人はもうクタクタ疲れているはずなんです
明日病気になる可能性もある
やっと苦労した 貯めたお金も結構なくなっているはず
お風呂に入る元気はもう全くなく
そのまま倒れたような感じで
あっちこっちで寝ていて
では 一日中山で静けさを感じた人が
明日病気になるってことでありえないでしょう
疲れたということはありえないでしょう
何か損したということはありえないでしょう
ストレス溜まったということ全くありえないです
だから幸福の方がすごくより高いんです
しかし それは幸福だと欲的な思考悪いとは思わないんです
バカじゃないかというんです
そういうことで 我々はゆっくりゆっくりでもいいらしいし
もうとにかく涅槃マサンカッパ欲から離れる思考を新たに学んで経験しなくちゃわからないものなんです
今の自分の思考で理解しようと思ったっても
それはゴミだけだから
ゴミの中でも生ゴミの中で何かすごい素晴らしいものを発見するということはありえないんですね
それから物を与える気持ちもね
物をもらうとも楽しいんだけど
では与えることで楽しもうではないかと
自分大事に持ってるものは与える
与えて助かっていて それで喜びを感じると
何かをしてあげて そのしてあげたことで喜びを感じる
見返りを感じるんじゃ
見返り感じちゃうと期待すると
それはただの商売で だから見返りだけ狙ってお布施すると
1万円あげたら まあ 1億円ぐらいの得が返ってくるでしょうと
これはなかなか残念なことに
あんまりお布施にはなりませんね
価値がお布施になるんだけど
価値がすごく低くなるんですね
与えることをできた 与えられた
ああ 良かったと 離れることをできたと
それで自分の人格はいくらかマシになったと
そういうことで 見返りということ項目がない場合は
純粋に熱干はサンカッパなんです
まあ皆様瞑想しますから
この瞑想を楽しむ 娯楽にする
そういうふうに理解すればなんとかなるでしょうね
娯楽はいろいろあるんだと
私の娯楽は瞑想することである
何もしないで思考を止めることであると
すると これは明らかに熱干無サンカッパなんですね
しかし そこは俗世間のレベルのものなんです
それもないと 出世間の熱干は生まれませんね
次に 聖なる無漏 煩悩ないというね
無漏たる出世間的な 悟りの悟りを透かさせる
解脱を透かさせるというマッガンゲ
道の部品である道っていうのは悟ることなんですね
マッガっていうのは で
それぞれの部品になる証紙は何で何でしょうかと
これでヨウコビッケアリエチッタッサアナーチョティスチッタッサアリエマッガッササマンギノ
そこで比丘たちよ 誰かの心がアリエチって聖なる心になっちゃって
アナソーチって無漏の煩悩ない心になっちゃったところで
アリエマッガッサ 聖道にいわゆる聖なる道に入っている心
その時の思考 イタクコサンカッポ
その時で頭の考え アッパナ・ヴァーヤパンナ
これはすごい難しい もうこの人はもうサマーディ状態に入ってます
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でアッパナっていうのはサマーディ状態で
心のこの調子した状態
いわゆる思考ない状態を保とうと
それでも皆様実況中継でやってるでしょ
その時も実況中継しなくちゃいけないんですよ
思考がなくなっても でないと調子状態からガクンと落ちちゃうんです
なんとなく思考が減ったような気分になっちゃうと
実況中継をやめちゃうんですね
やることない 痛みもないし
別に思考妄想もないんだから
じっと待っていて それでもダメで
またもう 初めからやらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの思考もないも何もなく
煩悩もほとんど消えた状態で
煩悩消えたっていうことは
妄想がない状態 まだ悟ってないんです
妄想が消えてるんです
妄想が消えてると もう思考ないんだけど
やっぱりそれでもサティをずっと持っていくんですね
だからアッパナ 何でしたっけ？ヴィアパンナ
このある状態の心が達してあって
その状態で保っておく思考
チェーテソアヴィニローパナワチサンカール
とにかくこの喋りたいというある特定の衝動があるんです
この喋りたいという衝動で頭の中で考えているんです
それがさらに管理できなくなっちゃうと喋るんです
衝動はサンカーラですよ
ワチサンカールというんですよ
言葉のサンカーラ まあ身口意に分けてますね
行為は それで苦の行ですね
喋りたいという衝動があって
頭の中でもずっといろんな概念がもうぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃもう書いてます
普通はいつでもありますよ
この 3つの身口意の行は
サンカーラがいつでも衝動はポテンシャルがいつでもあります
肉体を動かしたいというポテンシャルの
喋りたいというポテンシャルも
考えたいというこの場合はありますけど
とにかくこの場合は このワチサンカーラ
言葉に概念にしたがる気持ち
その気持ちが 聖なる衝動なんです
難しいんですよ だから人に何かなったわけじゃないんです
普通の喋りたい衝動で悪いことばっかり考えていたんですね
喋ったりしていたんですね
今度はこの喋りたい あるいは考えたいというエネルギーが概念のない状態になったんです
エネルギーはそのままでも質が違う
もっとわかりやすい説明の方法は考えておきます
今日はあまりいろんなことを即席なことをやっていたんだから
うーん 頭の調整できなかったんです
うーん これ 瞑想の経験でしか説明できないんですけど
瞑想していると どうしてもこの概念
頭の中であれこれあれこれともう喋ってるでしょう
いくらなんでも このエネルギーはすごいもんで消えませんね
で そのエネルギーを使って思考したい
エネルギーを使って思考しないことにするでしょ
実況中継ってのはそういうからくりでしょ
妄想することは思考であって
妄想に妄想ということも思考なんですけど
妄想 妄想ということも思考なんですね
妄想もしちゃうと妄想できなくなっちゃうんですね
しかし また妄想しちゃう
また妄想を持ってきちゃうんですね
そこで妄想しないことになったんですけど
ポテンシャルの 妄想しないんだからポテンシャルだけはあるんですね
で 妄想できなかった状態っていうのは
かなりサマーディも上がっていて
ヴィパッサナーのもう頂点に立った時なんですよ
そのヴィパッサナーの頂点に立った時
思考したい 喋りたい気持ちはあるんだけど
ないよ 話 そちらで欲の思考も全くない
真偽の思考も外義的な思考ももう全くゼロ
とにかくこの解脱 この出世間的なチョイスレベルの場合は
このかなりレベル違います
明確に違う それがサンマーサンカッパ
サンマーサンカッパっていうのはよく考えることであって
このサティには別に考える必要はないんで
本当は気づきだからね
でも気づきだけではもうすぐ落ちちゃいますよ
だから単語使ったりします
上げる下げるとかね 膨らんでいる
縮んでいるとかね 膨らんでいる
縮んでいると言わないで
膨らみ縮み感じてだけいると
別な方向でぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ
邪思惟がもう限りなく回転する
私は実況中がややこしいんだから
ただじーっと感じてるだけですよと言っても
見栄を張ってるだけで正しくはないんです
心理学は知らないんだからね
だから言葉使ってこの邪思惟を抑えなくちゃいけないんですね
それでやがて邪思惟消えちゃうんですね
邪思惟が消えたことが正思惟なんです
だから三すり台という必要はないんです
邪思惟が消えた状態だから
だからその時は単なる思考という風に言葉を使うんです
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ
瞋恚って言ったっけ え？瞋と瞋
ヴィタッカっていうのは言葉を使って考えること
ヴィチャーラっていうのは言葉なく考えることなんですね
二種類に考え方あるんですよ
で 頭が早い人はだいたい言葉なく考えるんですね
頭が遅い人は言葉で考えているんですね
いい例っていうのは数学なんですけど
数学はいっぱい言葉 単語を使ってますね
チャートやらいろんなもので
それで数学は上手ない人もすごい苦労して
もう高速点高い点数出す人もいるんですね
で 苦労している人はいつでもチャート書いて書いて
数字書いて書いて書いて書いて
うまくあれこれやってやってやって
やっと答え出す 言葉を使わない人がサッと答え
これでこれでこう出ましたよと言うんですね
だから数学の場合でも
すごい概念使わない思考できる人の方がすごく早いんです
どんな の世界の でもあんまり言葉単語を使う人はすごい遅いんです
まあ結果から見ればそんな大差はないかもしれませんだけど
遅いことは遅いんですね
そこで思考は 2種類 言葉で思考することと言葉なしに思考することと 2種類あります
お釈迦様はどちらでも使うんです
だから思考があるんだけど
邪思がないと この何の思考かというと
このサマーディ状態に心を持っていく言葉で
それだけ これが出世間の正思惟なんです
えーと それで 3セット説明します
そこで邪思をなくそうと精進するでしょう
頑張らないと邪思なくなりませんだからね
もともと本来あるのは邪思なんですよ
だから瞑想に来ると あなたの思考は全部ダメっていうのは決して待っと走りじゃないんです
その通りなんです 思考を止まりなさいよ
ストップしなさいっていうのは
それもそれで決して待ったなしじゃないんです
それで邪思やめるために精進しないと
ただでは生まれませんよ
因果法則ですからね だから解脱はただで得られると
お祈りすれば解脱で天国
永遠の天国に行けるんだと
神を信仰すれば永遠の天国に来るのかということはもう話にならないほど邪見なんです
何一つも何か努力しなきゃ得られないもんですよ
これは因果法則なんですよ
待っただけで結果出るということはありえないんです
お腹が空いたらじーっと待っているとご飯は出てくるわけじゃないんです
だから行動っていうのは
というか 精進するということはどうしても必要なんです
そういうわけで 邪思やめろではないかという努力が正精進なんです
そこで彼が邪思やめちゃって
サティでもって邪思をやめて
サティでもって少々正思惟に
間違ったサティでもって邪思をやめて壊して
サティで正思惟に達するんですね
サティっていうのは気づくことだから
気づかなきゃもう知る世界は成り立ちません
だからこれ大事なポイントなんですよ
仏教心理学では 気づかなきゃ知ったことにはなりません
そこでサンマーサティも入り込みますね
それで 3つがあります
正思惟 それは正精進で成り立つんです
と同時に正念で成り立つんです
正念というのは気づきでしょ
気づきで知るんだから
しかし 努力しないと そこで不可分離の 3セットまたできるんです
正思惟 正思惟と えーと
忘れちゃった パーリ語にするしかない
えーと 正精進 正精進と正念
パーリ語で言えばサンマーサンカッパとサンマーワーヤーマとサンマーサティ
これが不可分離のセットになるんです
前も同じ 正見と正精進と正念が不可分です
はい このセットを覚えればもう省略はできると思いますが
タッラビクビサンマーディッティプッバンガマーラと
またお釈迦様は同じ調子で
それでは比丘たちよ 正見が先頭に立って次に何するのかと
次に正見が先頭に立つと言葉
わかるんだよと ミッチャーワーチャ
邪業と正語はわかりますよと
ありのままに これは邪業である
これは正語であるとわかるためには正見が必要なんです
正見が親分でいつでも先にいるんです
後ろサンセットでも回転するんです
正見もサンセットで回転するんです
それで邪業っていうのは
まあこれから あの正見というのは
邪業と正業をはっきり区別する
明確に区別することできます
それで邪業って何でしょうか？というムサーワーダ
嘘をつくこと ヴィスナーワーチャ
二枚舌ですね パルサーワーチャ
粗悪語 それから無駄話
四つですね その四つはわかりやすい
二十四時間やっているんだからね
喋っている言葉何やと言えば
まあ嘘か無駄話か 二枚舌か
まあそんなところかな
粗悪語 そこで正語って何やというと
これは二つだよと 俗世間の正語と解脱をもたらす出世間的な正語があるんだと
俗世間の正語は 徳を積んで幸福という結果を出してくれる
それは輪廻に幸福になるということで
出世間的な正語は解脱をもたらしてくれる
正語は二つですと そこで善になる
徳になる 功徳になる 正語は何でしょうかというと
ムサーワーダヴェーラマニ
嘘をつかないことにする
サンパッパラパーヤ サンパッパラパーヴェーラマニ
噂を言うことをやめてしまうんじゃなくて
ヴィスナーワーチャも噂することをやめてしまう
サンパッパラ無駄話をやめてしまう
粗悪語もやめてしまう
で 俗世間だから粗悪語を言いたいんだけど
言わないことにする 嘘を言いたいんだけど
言わないことにする 嘘がダメだと
無駄話したくてたまらんだけど
これ無駄話だからしないよと
と自分を管理するんですね
自己を制御するんだから
これすごい徳行 すごい善行になるなるんですね
それで幸福にはなります
確実に業になります   良い業になります
それから出世間の称号は何でしょうか？と
これで瞑想する人 瞑想して心が浄化して
仏道聖なる道にも入ってるんですね
そうすると わちとヴィラットラティ
ちょっと待って わちじゅったり
テーヒアーティヴィラティパティヴィラティヴェーラマニ
この言葉使い方について全く悪く使わないという気持ちがもう生まれているんです
まあ思考さえもなくなってるんだから
喋りたいという衝動もないんですよ
喋りたい衝動は思考に入れちゃったんです
この場合は 口で物質的に喋ることなんですね
当然もうなくなってるはずなんです
あのレベルに達したら
で 本人が実況中継で瞑想しなくちゃあかんだからね
これやめちゃうとサマディ状態落ちるんだから
こればっかりやってて余裕もないんです
だからやりたくはない
もう決してやらない気持ちになっているんです
その気持ちの変わり方が聖なる称号になっちゃいます
出世間的な称号になるんです
もっと悪い 簡単な言葉で言えば
喋れなくなっていると言った方がいいんです
喋れなくなってるだけじゃなくて
もう喋りたくもない 喋りたくないし
喋り たくなくなっていて
もう言葉死んでるんです
こう理解しておきましょうか
とにかく喋りたいという衝動があるんですね
言葉を発したいと その衝動が変わるんです
別な方向へ行ってるんです
それで正見ある人は正業と邪業がわかっていて
それから精進して邪業をやめて正業に達する
で 精進したんだからといって達しませんよ
気づきがなければ これが正語
これは邪語だとちゃんと気づいて
ところで頑張って達すんだから
3セットが出てくるのです
正語と正精進と正念という
これは不可分的に だからこれを回転するんですよ
だから面白いことは 正語と正精進
それから正念が正語を回転しているんだから
だからそのなんかわけのわからないこの回転システムがずっと大事に守っておくんです
例えば A が B を回っていると言えばわかりますよ A
と B が A を回っているというと
どうやって回っているのかと
回らへんでしょうということになっちゃうんで
これサマーディっていうのも入って
サマーディってのは先頭で
サマーディってが親分でいろんなことをやらせてるんだっていうこと
でもサマーディっても元気になるのはもう 3セットで
それで元気になって他のことをやらせるのも 3セット
3セットでやらせてるんです
だから一個一個完成された教えなんですけど
サマーディ優先にしなさいと
だから八正道など お釈迦様が何かリストを語る場合は
もう並大抵の智慧じゃない
もうブッダの智慧だからしょうがないんですけど
この順番とかね 決して変えてはいけない
だからなぜ八正道は循環するものであって
もう法輪にしているでしょうしね
どちらでもよろしいかやと言っているにも関わらず
一にしているのはこういうわけですということで
やっぱり親分はもう正見であると
そこでこのサンセット回転するのは何とか遺伝子みたいな感じで
このスパイラル状態で回転しているんです
だからどんどんどんどん上達するんですよ
スパイラル状態で回転するんだから
ただ 円の状態で回転すると上達はないんです
同じところでずっと回転だから
スパイラルだったらどうでしょうかと
上上行かないと 次 サンマーディッティが先にいて判断するんです
何を判断するのかというと
ミッチャーカンマンタン
正語 邪語 間違っている行為
それからまあ 邪語と正語
どちら伸ばすんですかね
言葉  邪語 正語ですね  うん
前は伸ばせないね  伸ばさない
言葉の場合 え？語の場合伸ばすね
今は伸ばす 前伸ばしちゃったんですけど
前は正語と言うべきところは語と言っちゃったんですけど
どうしましょうか え？はい
お願いします  語と語を入れ替える
今は語ですね 正語 それで邪語
それでサマーディッティで正見で正語を知っていて
邪語を知ってるんです
では 何でしょうかと 知っていると言ったっても
まあ邪語っていうのは殺生すること
盗むこと よこしまな行為
3つですね それはもう明らかに黒い
この 3つはひとかけらも白くはならない
灰色ではダメです 殺生ならもういかなる生命の殺生も黒いという風にしなくちゃ
訳があって殺したんだからといって殺しはダメと
日本は占領されたところで
日本人が戦争に行って人を殺したんだからといって
もうこれはもう訳があるんだからといって
言い訳は言い訳で勝手にしろよと
しかし 業は業であると
私の言い訳によって業がね
カルマが変わるんだったらありがたいことでしょうね
いろいろ悪いこと言って言い訳すればいいんだからね
そうはなりません 国を守るためであろうが
家族を守るためであろうが
どんな言い訳でもっても
やっぱり殺生では罪になるんですね
人が死にかけているんだから
食べるものなくて だからわしは盗んであげましたよと
いいことだよ はいいわけであって
盗んだことは邪業で 人にあげて死にかけて人を助けたこと
それはまあいいことで基本です
行為単位で だからその人は罰が受ける
受く場合は盗んだことで不幸になって
死にかけてた人を助けたことで
それは善行為 そういう意味では
幸福になるという 業はそういうふうに塗り替えやらなくちゃいけないんです
切って切って切って切って
トータル的にそうすると灰色ではないかと
この人やったことはね
盗んで食べさせたことは
それはごちゃ混ぜにすると灰色になるんであって
ごちゃ混ぜにすることはできん
物事はもう一個ずつ単位で動いています
例えば灰色のものでも
顕微鏡で見ると白色のものと黒色のものは別々だからね
モンギャルと見ると灰色であって
ジーッと顕微鏡で見ると灰色じゃないんです
そこで では正業は何なのかというと
また 2種類 俗世間的で善行であって
良いカルマになって幸福をもたらしてくれる正業がありますよと
もう一つ 解脱をもたらしてくれる
すべての煩悩をなくなっちゃって
完全たる解脱をもたらしてくれる正業があるんだよと
そこで徳になりまして
良いカルマになりまして
幸福になる 輪廻転生すると幸せになる
正業っていうのは まあ殺さないこと
盗まないことと 欲しもない行為をやめることですよ
やりたくてもやめておく
で 聖なる道は やっぱり瞑想で心は超絶レベルに達したところで
心で行為したいという気持ちが
あの衝動が変わっているんです
だから衝動があるんだけど
全く変わってるんですね
行為したいではなくて
したくないっていう方に変わっているんです
衝動が消えたっていうことは使ってないんです
物質世界ではね 例はないな
とにかく思考したい気持ちもなくなっているでしょう
当たり前に喋りたい気持ちとね
体を動かしたい気持ちはなくなっているはずなんです
しかし エネルギーはもう超越した方向へ行っているんです
それはものすごく強烈なエネルギーなんですよ
純粋にとってみると それでサンマーサンカップの場合も 3セットになりますね
それで正見様が親分で
あの正語サンマカンマンタですね
正見様が親分で正語を引き起こすんですね
まず正業と邪業を区別してくれて
それから精進と気づきで正業に達するんです
というわけで 正業と正精進と正念が正業を回っているんです
物で考えれば回るわけじゃないんだけど
まあこの場合はちゃんと回っているんです
スパイラルで回っているんです
次にあるのは正命ですね
正命 妙っていうのはアージーヴァだからね
これはもうね 何でしょうかね
職業のことなんですね
仕事のことです じゃあ説明省略して省略して持っていきます
で 正妙サンマーアージーヴァ
妙という漢字がちょっと怪しい
それはまあ自称的で音訳しているんだだからね
そこで正見様がもうちゃんとこれを区別すると
これは邪妙ミッチャーアージーヴァ
これがサンマーアージーヴァ
正妙とちゃんと区別して
それでは区別すると結果は何なのかというと
邪妙っていうのは 随分簡単に書いてます
間違ってる生活をやめて正しい生活をするんだと
邪妙は間違って ちょっと待ってくださいと
うーん ミッチャージーヴァ
あ ミッチャージーヴァ
間違ってる生活はもうわかりやすく書いてます
クハナラパナネミッタカタ
クハナっていうのはもう
これ日本語の単語を調べてください
詐欺  詐欺ですね で ラパナっていうのはもう言葉巧みに騙すことなんです
ネミッタカっていうのは
まあ本当は占ったりとかね
日平石 日平石がどうなってますか
威嚇って書いてあります
ん？威嚇するっていう
脅すみたいな  こちらはペテンとか詐欺とか同じことですね
なんか随分読めない漢字もありますけど
結局のある詐欺師種類ですね
まあコハナという 1番目っていうのは
本当は うーん まあ詐欺っていうより詐欺師というよりも
まあ微妙にからくりして生活することなんですね
ん 読めないですね  読めないんですよ
ヤクザとかヤクザみたいな
そういう いや コハナっていうのは大体ほとんどみんなやってますよ
ちょっとあるものはないとして
ないものはあるとして見せかけたりして
それでもう本当は仕事は頑張ってない
昨日すごく疲れますよ
頑張りましたと言ったりしてね
ああ そうですか そうですかと
そうか 手品師はいいんですか？ うーん
そちらは入ってないんでしょうね
これはまあ日常茶飯事でやってる
もう で 仕事をしたい気持ちもないのに
そういう顔を見たら もうやる気満々で
それは嘘ですね それで課長がもう騙されちゃうでしょ
あいつはいい人だからって言って
まあそこで放っておいたりしてね
で 私はこのちっちゃな子供たちに教えている時でも
もう見るまるまるっきり見え見えですけど
勉強したくないし 出した宿題やってないっていうことで
そこでまあ本人がやる気がないんだから
こちらもまあ別に押さえたって意味がないっていうことで
まああまり気にしないんだけど
そこでたまたま他のところに行くと一生懸命
あれはクハナなんですよ
あのビーンさんの映画でよく見せてる
あれは冗談でね まあ鉛筆をこうやったりしてる
本当は何一つも返事できないんですね
試験場に行っちゃって
自分がこの質問状間違っちゃって
2枚ありまして 自分が勉強したものじゃなくて別なものを取っちゃって
このスタティスティックというもので
これやっぱりわからない
で こうやったり で 隣の人になんとか
そういう感じでね まあ我々普通の人間ってそうやってもう本当にいろんなこと見せかけちゃうんですね
正直にもうやってないとかね
今日はやる気持ちはないとかは言わないんですね
そうするとすぐ場が悪くなるんだと
私の場合はすごい場が悪くなるで
正直に言うんだから 今日はやるつもりはありませんと
そう言ったら強引にやらせてもいい結果は出ない
こちらはもう調子に乗らないんだから
もう今日はいくらなんでもやる気持ちにはならないと
普通は言わないんでしょ
あ そうですか ではもうなんとかもうやりましょうとかね
普通なんですね そういう生き方は
まあこれは仕事に関わるんだからね
結構やります 勉強でクハナやっちゃうと何にも得られませんだけどね
勉強するつもりでいたりとかね
もうそれではもう本を開けて
間に漫画を本を挟んでもう徹夜したってもね
で それで親を騙すかもしれませんだけど
それではもう でも会社に行ったらまた同じことをやってますね
それはクハナで ラパナっていうのは言葉巧みに使うことで
クハナ ラパナ ニイミッタカタっていうのは
このやっぱり占いですよ
占いと暗示も入り まあちょっと説明しますね
ミッタカタの うーん ニイミッタカタっていうのはやっぱり占いと書いてますね
うん これあの占いだけではないんですよ
あの株の世界ではよく使うんですよ
占って金儲かることも正しくない
もう明らかに邪妙 で 例えば株の場合はいろいろ分析したりして
こうでしたらこうでしたら
おそらくこのこの株はまあ上がる方向でしょうとか
なんだらかんだらと言ってるでしょ
それであんまり上手に株の売買できない人々は
そうやって人の話聞いて
人の話を聞いてから まあここら辺にやってやろうかなとか思ったりもする
で あのなんとか会社がね
あの 何でしたっかの会社名前忘れちゃった
堀江さんのライブドアのとかね
なんとなく一般人になんとなくそういう暗示を行くんですね
あ これ会社がうまくいきそうだなとかね
はっきり言わない はっきり言ったら法律違反だからね
そうやってなんとなく
なんかこれからこの品物は抜群に売れそうだなという人は
みんな飛んで行って買ったりするしね
コマーシャルの場合は
まるっきり売ってる品物と何の関係もない画像を出して品物を来るでしょ
もう面白くて全くも論理性っていうのはないんですね
アメリカのコマーシャルと比べると
アメリカのコマーシャルでは明らかにもう派手に論理的にこれはダメ
だからこれ買いなさい
そんな感じなんですけど
で タバコの会社のコマーシャルがありましてね
まあもう美しい自然も環境があって
なんだらそれタバコを吸いなさいじゃやめなさいということはありませんね
だからなんかまるっきり違う
あまりコマーシャルを思い出せないな
大体どんなコマーシャルでも
それそういったかなり使ってますね
ねえ 見た方っていうことは
この品物はいいものだから買いなさいとは全然言わない
小さな車のに もうもうもう荷物運ぶんですね
家一軒ぐらいの で そんな感じでもうなんと感じてしまうんですね
買ってみたところで話は違うんじゃないかということになりますけど
それで まあよく考えましたと
自然を大事に守ることは優先先に考えましたと
だからこの車を作りましたよと
どんな話でしょうかと
車を使っちゃうと自然破壊するんですけど
それもねえ 見た方ということに入ります
インドではそこまではコマーシャルなかったんだからね
裏なしなんですね 次の何でしたっけ？密閉しかっていうのは詐欺師ですね
次はこのラベンのラバンニジギンセナタ
えっと あらゆる得の話をね
儲かる話でごまかすということですね
例えば 株に興味のない人のところに行って
まあお金寝かしておいたってもね
1円にもならないでしょうと
動かした方がいいんだよと
それでももう銀行に預けても利息はないし
タンスに置いておいたってもそのまんまで危ないし
だからまあ 2割でも 3 割でも入ったらそれ得でしょうと
いうふうに話したりして
いい株がありますからね
そこをもう何も心配することはない
そうやってもう なんとか得の話をして
それは本当にいいかどうか関係なく
もう儲かってしまうんですね
まあいろいろこのもうもうそういう風にも
まあ悪い商売することですから
もっといい例がないかな
二次元性なんてのは貪欲欲という辞書を引いても意味が取れないんですですからね
まあとにかくまあこういうことを言ったら
あなた儲かりますよというのは結局自分の儲かりなんですけどね
こうしなきゃ こうしなきゃとかね
まあ例えばこういう まあいろいろ機械ありますね
もう例えば田んぼを畑でするか機械ありますね
売りたいんですけど 人が田んぼがやりたくなくて
土地はあるんですけど
そちらに行ってね あんたこの土地を寝かしておいてはできませんよと
もうどれぐらい収入得ると思ってるんでしょうかと
ただでもうもうちょっと
一回 1週間  2週間苦労するだけでね
それで体にもいい それから自然にもうもう農作物出るでしょうにと
なんでそんな土地あるのに
あんたそんなことを苦労しているのかとか
でもこの土地はね もう畑にするのは難しい
もう大丈夫 もう機械やりますからね
たった 1時間で平らになりますよ
じゃあもうやるんだったら
もう一応割引引いてね
あの まああんたに特別にもうもうもう一応元の原価であげますよと
私はやっぱりこの土地はもう心配やと
そのまま放っておいて
あんたのこと心配やと
それで原価で売るということで
これにあまり言うともう機械買っちゃうんですね
そこで言ってる人は もう自分が儲かりたいだけ
品物を売りたいだけなんですけど
相手に得の話ばっかり持っていくと得するのは相手だよと
買ったら知ったもんかと
あの人はあれで借金しているのに知ったもんかと
そういう調子になっちゃうし
言って別なところに別なカモを探しちゃうんですね
そういうふうな生き方
生きるための仕事でしょ
だから明らかにこの正命
邪命っていうのは仕事のことで
そういうことが邪命で
正命っていうのは 俗世間の正命っていうのは
簡単に説明してます 悪い仕事をしないで
正しい仕事で生活すると
それで常識でいいんですよ
自分は正しい仕事をしているんだと
誰も騙してはないし ごまかしてはないし
ごく普通の仕事で生きていますよということで
それは俗世間のレベルで
それで正命の場合は俗世間のレベルでは仕事になったんですね
我々は仕事をして品物を得なくちゃいけないんですよ
体のために家という品物
食べるものという品物
服という品物 娯楽に行くならば
それも一つの品物なんですね
で それは得るためには
自分が何か収入がないとできないんですね
しかし 瞑想になってくると
もっと正命が微妙な意味が変わるんですよ
生きる命でしょうし 生きることなんですね
だから今の瞬間で生きているんですけど
次の瞬間でも生きなくちゃいけないんですね
それで生き続ける衝動
それがあって 生き続けるためにはご飯を食べなくちゃいけないんだと後から話になるんですよ
幸福で生き続けるためには
もう気持ちのいい色のいい服を買わなくちゃいけないんだよと
薬も飲まなくちゃいけないんだよっていう風になるのは
随分後の話なんですよ
一番真っ先に我々は衝動を持ってますよ
サンカーラが持ってるんです
ポテンシャルは生き続けたいという
出世間の正命の場合はそれになっちゃうんです
それでサマーディを得て瞑想して出世間レベルに達した人でも思考も何もないし
正見があるんだから 生きることはもう苦であるともうとっくにわかっているし
ですから生き続けますよという話にならんでしょうに
生きることはもう食うのみ
他何もあらそとわかっている人は
したがって私は徹底的に生きてみるぞということになりませんね
それであの衝動はどうなるんですか？あのポテンシャルが形変わるんです
俗世間では生きる意味がないんだと思ったら自殺するでしょうに
あれはもうもう何の話にもなりません
欲がなければ怒りですよという話です
ヴィパッサナー地になった人は生きる気持ちがなくなってますよ
しかし 自殺 自殺の気持ちも生まれません
自殺は答えだから 早くも自殺した方がいいでしょうに
瞑想もしないで いっぱいご飯食べて
もういっぱい遊んで はい
これから自殺するそうと
その方が楽でしょうに
だから自殺は答えじゃないんだ
自殺でもどこかに生まれるんだから
生き続けることは避けられない基本的な衝動なんです
基本的なポテンシャルなんですね
これで生き続けたいという気持ちがもう無色透明になっちゃうんです
しかし エネルギーはエネルギーなんです
その場合も間違っているものから離れるということで
自然の流れで法則で もうこれは回転するならば勝手にしちゃってもいいんだけど
自分ではわざわざと伸ばさない
伸ばしたいということはないんだっていう
勝手に生き続くなるば勝手にやりなさいよと
悟った場合は 完全に悟った場合
その調子なんです もう勝手に体が死なないんだったらご飯あげますけど
まあもうグダグダ壊れますよね
じゃあいいよ 壊れてくださいと
ということになるんです
とにかくこのこれも超越したレベルで
それまたサンセットで回転する
聖賢様がまあ邪命と正命を区別してくれて
次に精進して気づきで邪命をやめて正命に達する
ですから このサンセットはぐるぐる回転していますね
サンセットは正命と正精進と正念ですね
その 3つが正命を回転しているんです
次にまた聖賢様が先に先頭に立って
次に何するのか というと
うん 次にはテキストパーチャ
何ページにしてるの？忘れた
７６ページだと思いますけど ７５
ページの下から  うーん
サッマディッティ サンマサンカッパ入ってますけど
あ 違う サッマディッティセビクウェサッマサンカッポパホーティ
サンマサンカッパサッマワーチャーパホーティ
一応まとめているんですね
正見ある人には正思惟できますよと
正思惟がある人には正語できますよと
今度は正解でしたね 正語できる人には正業できますよと
正業できる人には正命できますよと
それで正命ある人は正精進できますよと
正精進ある人にはどうしても正念ありますよと
もう完成しているんだよと
正念あれば正定 正しい心の統一生まれますよと
それで正定 正しい心の統一ある場合は正知ニャーナ
正恵ですね 知恵の恵だけ
正慧ができますよと 正慧あるいは智慧
正しい智慧がある人にはサンマービムって正しい解脱が成り立つんだよと
それでこの成功 パティパダーはいわゆる有学のセクション
いわゆる預流果から不還果までは有学ですね
預流道から不還果まで有学というんですね
まだ学ぶものを残っていると
それで有学無学も仏教の意味は違いますからね
無学っていうのはもう完全な智慧が完成したということで
何もわからない人って意味じゃないんです
学はなしって意味じゃないんです
学ぶものはなしって意味なんです
俗世間では学問していないということで無学というんですけどね
仏教用語では学ぶものはなしっていうことで
いわゆる全部もう知り尽くしているんです
有学っていうのは まだ学ぶものは残しているということで
そこでこの八項目で成り立つんだよと
有学は 無学は十項目で成り立つんだよと
八で十って何ですか？ 八項目は八正道なんですね
八正道で有学です 悟ったらサンマーニャーナ
サンマービムって言って二つ入るんです
正へと正解脱 すると十なんですね
八に二つ足すんです それで無学なんです
なんか進むんだけど ちょっと
では 経典の通りに読んでみます
タトラビッカーでサンマディッティプッバンガマホーティカタンジャビクウェサッマディッティプッバンガホーティ
サッマディッティセビクウェミッチャーディッティニッジンナホーティ
単語を変えるだけ サッマディッティ様がもう親分で先にいて
何するのかというと サッマディッティによってミッチャーディッティがニッジンなんていうのは衰えてしまう
いわゆる腐敗する 正見によって邪見が腐敗して壊れていきますと
それからイエーチャミッチャーディッティパッチャヤ
邪見によって現れるアネーケパッパカクサラダマ
あらゆる不善のこと 悪いことがすべて腐敗していくと
邪見によって一切の悪いこと生まれてくるんです
すべての悪が すべての不幸が
邪見が親分なんです それで正見があったらもう邪見が腐敗するんだから
壊れてもう錆びて死にますから
全ての悪いことはそれで錆びて腐敗していきますよと
それから正念によってあらゆる善が増えますよと
完成しますよと バハナパーリプーリアバハナっていうのは瞑想と訳しますけど
バハナというのは向上という意味なんですね
向上することが完成しますよと
で まあこちらではあんまり瞑想瞑想っていう単語をあんまり私は専門的には使いませんだから人格向上
人格向上っていう言葉を使っているんです
向上っていうのは バハナっていう言葉のはっきりした日本語の訳なんです
まあ成長するという意味ですから
で だから瞑想もバハナですが
瞑想瞑想というと何か別な意味も入ってしまっちゃうし
だから向上という人格向上という
それは完成するんですね
それで正思惟があれば
邪思惟が何でしたっけ？腐敗していく
それで邪思惟によって現れる一切の悪業を悪業が腐敗になってしまいます
それから あらゆる善行為が完成して
人格向上も完成するんだと
で 次に正語ですね 正語によって邪語
邪語が腐敗して 邪語によって生まれるすべて悪も腐敗していくんだと
正語から生まれる善も完成して
人格向上も完成しますよと
そのように次のセットも全部正語
邪語によってじゃなくて
正語によって邪語が腐敗して
邪語から生まれる悪もなくなっちゃって
もう善も完成して人格は向上する
正命によって邪命が腐敗してしまう
それで邪命によって生まれる不善もなくなってしまって
善は完成して人格向上をするんだと
で  77 ページに行っちゃうと
そこでやっとサンマワーヤムセクションが入ります
サンマワーヤム 正精進によって間違っている精進が腐敗すると
間違っている精進によって生まれるあらゆる不幸が悪が腐敗するんだと
それ代わりに正しい精進で正精進によってあらゆる善が満たしていって
人格向上も完成するんだよと
次に正念 正念によって邪念が腐敗すると
それで 気づきなんですね
正しく気づくか 間違って気づくかという
例えば 夜暗闇で何か触ったら
何か丸くて長くて感じたらロープじゃないかなと
と気づく あ ロープだと
本当はヘビですと えっと
これ邪念 間違った気づきでしょ
それで噛まれて死んだりする
暗闇で触ったところで
何かヌルヌルで触れた
あ これはヘビじゃ これはヘビやと気づいちゃうと
すぐ手を離して身を守るでしょうね
だから気づくことも 正しく気づく
間違って気づくということがありますね
だから科学世界ではいつでも発見は改良していくのはそういうことなんですね
最初は気づいて あ これこれこうじゃないかなと結論出しますけど
さらに数学的に考えて
機械は開発して さらにさらに調べると
あ 違うんだ 別なものやというふうに発見するでしょうね
だからその場合は 科学者は自分の気づきのギリギリのところで頑張ってますけど
そちらにももう当たるか当たらないかということがありますね
だから気づきだからいつでもというわけじゃなくて
間違って気づく場合もありますね
時々もう怠けていることは心はおざなりになってるんだというふうに間違って気づく場合もあるでしょ
瞑想すると いえ 私にはあんまり妄想が出てこないんだから
普通にじーっとしてるんだよと
これ 心が機能しない状態になって
いわゆる昏睡睡眠状態に陥っているのに
本人がサマーディに入ってるんだと
それは気づきが間違ってますね
邪念ですよ 正念ではなくて
あるいは長い間瞑想していて
瞑想が本当に楽しみになったところで
どうせ欲世界に対して興味がなくなっているんです
瞑想は楽しくて これはもう極楽になっちゃって
もう音楽やら金儲けることもう興味
あれ 俺に煩悩がないんじゃないかなと
ということは悟ってるんじゃないのかと
これがもう邪念なんですね
で 邪念に気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
これは俗世間で論ではあまり語らないところだから
お釈迦様はそこを全部抜かしちゃって
最後に邪念 だから見てください
お釈迦様はサンセットサンセットで称妙で止めたんです
称妙でサンセットの論語をちゃんと止めて
それから有学無学の説明に入ったんですよ
だからいい加減マンネリでやっているわけじゃないんです
すっごく気をつけてるんです
しかし あといくつかのもう正念と少々人と少将が残っているんですよ
3つ で 別な枠でその 3つを説明して持っていくんです
で まあ精進間違ったら大変なことになるんだ
で 気づき間違ったらまた大変なことになるんだよと
このヴィパッサナー瞑想で
なんでこの指導者がいる？指導者にやること何もないんですよ
一人でやる瞑想だから
この気づきをもし間違ったら困りますからね
結構間違うんですよ そこは直して直して持っていくんです
で これって一人でもできますけど
簡単です 自分の結論は考えた結果だったらもう間違い
思考が間違いなんです
あれといえば悟ってるんじゃないかなっていろいろ考えてることで悟ってないんです
私は怒らないとは思いますけど
やっぱりダメです 怒りますよ
そいつは 逆にもう無茶怒りたいんだけど
どうも怒れないんですね
と言えば ちょっとそれはもう本物ですよ
怒りたいんだ なんで怒らないのはこんなもの怒るのかと
いい 私が怒りがないと思いますと言っちゃうと
これで気づきが間違ってます
だからもうよく私にも言ってる人はいます
あ やっと終了しましたとかね
それはどういうふうに？それでまあ
こういうことで あ そう
で アウトです それでやたらにこのもう見栄を張って仏教専門用語使うでしょうに
だから私はパーリ語だったらもうそれなりにしてんだけど
私は使ってないでしょうに
たまたま初めてもう歳になってパーリ語という言語を知っ
あることを知った人が
あのサマーディに今サマーディ状態で
これからあの全部もう老婆
今老婆童話もうもう話にならない
これやたらに専門用語を使って人を騙すんじゃないんです
だからもう確実にブッダの使った専門用語っていうのはすごい完璧であって安全なんですけど
我々にとってはこれ異文化でしょうに
経験はないでしょうに
だから見栄張らないで私が使う言葉でやるか
皆様方 自分でわかった
それなりの単語でやるか
例えばこの実況中継という単語は
私はこちらで上である
ものすごくかなり前 何人かの人に瞑想を教えていると
ある女性のおばさんがなんか実況中継することでしょう
あ これがこの方 どの単語でいいやと
なぜその方が使った単語を私は今専門用語として使っているんです
それでいいんです 別に私が考えて作ったわけじゃないんです
で その場合ははっきり意味があるんです
ですから このとにかく悟ったんではないかとか
この位置にいるんではないかというではないか
ではないか ではないかではないんです
で この経典でもずっと言いたいのは
もうもう曖昧じゃないんだよと
もう涅槃というのはなんとなく曖昧
わからない行持 そんな気休めの世界じゃないんだよと
びっしりした もうびっしりした具体的な言葉です
そこでサンマワヤも正精進によってあらゆる悪いことがなくなって
良いことだけで人格は完成するんだと
それはすぐにサンマサティマ説明しましたね
それからサンマサマーディ
精浄 正しい心の統一 正しい心の整え方によって間違った集中力がなくなりますと
まあサマーディは集中力だと言った方が分かりやすいんですね
正しい集中力と間違っている集中力
そこで間違った方向の集中しちゃうととんでもなく間違っちゃうでしょうに
ですから 正しい集中力が生まれたら
間違った集中力から生まれるすべての苦しみも悪も苦もなくなって
正しい集中力から生まれるすべての善は満たしてしまって
人格も向上する 完成する
2つ言うんですよ 善は満たしていく
それは即席のレベルで人格が完成するということは出世
世間の悟りの境地で 次にあの九番目も十番目も説明する
サンマニャーナン 正しい慧
智慧の慧です 正しい慧によって正慧
によって邪慧ですね 智慧の慧と邪邪邪見の邪と慧
邪慧がなくなるんだと
で その正しい智慧っていうのは
やっぱりこの一切現象ということと
無常と空と無我を発見することなんで
本当にやるのはそれだけですよと
あるとは言えないんだからね
だって無常はどこにあるのかって言ったって意味がないでしょうに
現象があると無常が成り立つんであってね
こちら花があると花が枯れるという
枯れてごちゃになるってことで
花がなければもう関係ないんですよ
花が枯れるという話は
こちら建物があるんだから
建物が古くなる やがて壊れるという無常が成り立つんであって
建物がなければ建物が壊れる
無常という話になりません
だから一切の行ですね
行は無常であるというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
では行がなければと話にならん
そんなのは このビルがあるとすると古くなるんだよ
壊れるんだよという無常の話は成り立つんであって
ビルが初めからなかったらもう話にならんでしょう
そういうこともあります
言葉にならない 返事はなしという
涅槃はどういうことかと
もう言葉にならないと
話にならない だから解脱と言います
解脱っていうのは出世間から脱出世間は現象としてあるんだからね
そこから脱出すると だから家にいた人が地震で野原に逃げたと
野原にいた人を野原に逃げたっていうのは話にならんでしょうに
安全な避難場所があって
まあそちらにもともといる人はそちらにそのままでしょうしね
だから危険な家がある
その中にいた人が避難所に逃げなくちゃいけないんです
だから現象の世界にいる人が解脱にあって解脱したところっていうことは話にならないんです
そういうことで ミッチャーニャーナとサンマニャーナがあるんです
あの邪慧と正慧があるんです
邪慧っていうのは 世の中はこうではないか
ああではないかとかね
もういわゆるすべての説は邪慧なんです
いろんな学説 論理あるでしょう
全部邪慧なんです まあ無常ということを
現象は無常である 行は無常であるとわかる智慧が正慧なんですね
それによって現象はあるんだそうと思っている人々
やっているはの間違い
全部なくなります 例えば
この世の中あるんだそうと思ったんだから
この世の中を創った人がいるんだよという推測成り立つでしょうに
創った人がいるんだから
その人のところに逃げた方が安全だよと
これって推測成り立つでしょうに
明らかに人間の勝手な考え方なんですね
だから論理的でもないんですね
この世はある よくよく見るとあると成り立ちませんよ
まあそこは許してあげても
あるんだから創った人もいるんだそうと
これで何の証拠もなく成り立つんですね
それでその人のところに行ったら救えますよというのはどういう話でしょうかと
だから その人が作った世界は危険であるならば
本人の方がなおさら危険だよということは論理でしょうに
苦しみに溢れた逆肉共食の世界がある
この世界が作った人もいる
逃げるならそいつから逃げよということでしょうに
論理で考えれば まあとにかくこの現象があるという科学者も現象があるという科学者はしょうがないんですよ
物理学やってますからね
であるというところから調べていって
で そこから調べて出す発見というのは
それほど無常にはまあ
出てこないんですね だから邪ね
邪慧でいっぱい罪を犯す羽目になります
それで正慧が生まれたら
あの罪が全部なくなって
正しい智慧があるんだから
やることは何でもかんでも良いことになってしまいます
それで終わらないんです
出世間のレベルで人格向上もします
それで邪慧じゃなくて正慧
ある人にとっては正解脱があるんですね
正解脱に達した人は それで邪解脱はなくなっています
邪解脱って何でしょうかね
解脱やと勘違いすることですね
それで間違って解脱しているんだぞと思っている人とは
あらゆる罪を犯しちゃうでしょうね
麻原彰晃いい例でしょうね
私は最終解脱者だと だから私は何やってもいいんだと
最終解脱者が生えたお風呂の水でご飯を炊いて食べなさいよと
あなたは早く悟りますよと
しかし 水一杯はこれぐらい値段だよと
でお風呂に入った水をほんのちょっとちょっとみんな持っていって飲んだりして
で それで金儲かってますね
本人金 それは悟っているんだから金儲かってもよろしい
いろんな女の人と不倫やっていたでしょうね
それはもう解脱者がいっぱい子供を作った方が世の中のためになるんだと
だからもう邪解脱 それは本人は解脱していない
解脱しているというただ嘘をついているんですけど
もし本当にそうだと勘違いしたらどうなるんですか？もっとひどいでしょう
だから悪が一応正解脱によって悪がなくなるんです
人格は向上します それで不善の方に二十項目入りました
八正道に二つつけますよ
だから邪道にも二つつけますね
八正道あるならば八邪道があるんです
それで智慧と慧と智慧と使わないんですよ
使えないんです 邪慧も使わなくちゃいかんだからね
智慧というと パンニャーというパーリ語の訳なんです
それはもう正しいに決まってるんです
ニャーナというパンニャーではなくて
ニャーナという言葉に変えているんです
だから邪慧と正慧 それで八正道
よく耳に口に慣れている言葉で八邪道もあります
それに邪慧と邪解脱入れちゃうと二十です
十ですね 正道の場合は八正道に正慧と正解脱入れちゃうと十ですね
それで悪の方で十と善の方で十と足したら二十になります
で こちら十と こちら計算間違いではなくて
私の計算間違いですけど
こちら二十 二十にしています
これは１項目２つに分けてますね
どういう分け方かちょっとわからない
２つずつあったから サンマーディッティには２つ
でもミッチャーディッティに２つはないでしょう
３２はすぐだけど めっちゃ
あ こういうことだと思う
注釈書で説明していると思いますけど
また今日は難しいんだから
ただ一遍で斜めに読みながらではわからないんです
私にも 邪念が正念で邪念が消えると
邪念が悪で正念が善でしょ
それで正念によって邪念から生まれる悪も消えるんですね
それで邪念と悪が２つになりますと思いますね
それで正念によって善行為もできて
人格完成もする そうすると邪念の方に２つと正念の方に２つっていうことになっちゃうんですね
そうなってくると二重になるんです
なんかややこしいね じゃあ邪見にしましょう
邪見があって 悪が生まれて堕落する
悪の悪いこと２つで 邪見も悪いし
悪を犯して堕落することも悪いんですね
正念によって善行為もできて
人格向上もする ですから
正念も正しいし 結果も正しい
ということで 邪念２つ
邪見２つと正見２つにセットになる
そこで八正道が十正道になっちゃうし
八邪道が十邪道になっちゃうですよね
一個一個二つ二つ付いてるんです
結果とまとめて 原因と結果
原因と結果と それで二重二重
やっとできました そうすると悪の二重と善の二重で四重になりますよと
これは偉大なる四重の説法であると
ですから これはお釈迦様の智慧ではもっと語られますけど
我々にとってはもう形が超えすぎ
もうなかなか もう我々ね
初めからも私たちの思考次元とばして始まるんですよ
だから聞く人はなんななく上へ上がらなくちゃいけないんですよ
これマハーチャッターリイセカ
偉大なる四重というタイトルもつけてます
経典にも だから 経典の中で経典にタイトルをつけるところっていうのはそれほどないんです
ぐっとにもう覚悟を決めてもう語るぞという時に
時だけ経典にタイトルまでつけるんです
では語ってやろうではないかと
だから最初もお釈迦様が比丘たちの質問に答えてないでしょ
私言ったでしょうに お釈迦様はご勝手に喋ってるんだから気をつけましょうと
これはちょっと危ないんだけど
わからないんだ なるんだよと
お釈迦様はご自分で比丘たちよと呼びかけちゃうと
これから大変な難しい説法になるのはごく普通なんです
それで終わったところでも
ちゃんとまとめて四重項目ですと
これは偉大なる四重であると
ダンマパリアーヨ まあ法門ですね
四重の法門 パワッティとも言いましたよと
アッパティワッティよ
これには逆転すること
いわゆる間違ってるんだと言って反論して潰すことはお釈迦様も設定しました
いい あなたの意見は結論は成り立ちませんよと
なんて言いますか 批判して
別な結論になることなったことできませんと
アッパティワッティよ
もう逆転はできませんよと
こんなに自慢できるのはブッダだけなんです
誰にもこんな言ってることを間違ってると言えませんよと
サマネーナワー ブラームナーナワー
デーヴェーナワー マーレーナワー
シャモンであろうが バラモンであろうか
神であろうか マーラであろうか
ブラッムナーはブラン
ブラモンでブラフマであろうか
ケーネチワローカス 生命には誰にもできないよと
だから悟ったブッダだからこそ言える言葉で
こんな言葉あると この宗教そのもの壊れますよ
私は言うことは絶対的で
誰にも微妙にでもケチをつけることできませんと言ったら
世の中わからないんですよ
どんな知識人が現れるのかと
科学はどのように発展しているのかわからないでしょうに
でもいまだに壊れませんだからね
これからも壊れないんですよ
もうこれがもう最終的な真理ですよ
ヨヒコウチビクエサマノワブラームノワイマンマハチャッタアシカンダンマン
ダンマパリアヤンガラヒタッバンパティッコウヒタッバンマンニャイエ
もし誰かがこの四十年項目をね
非難してやろう 馬鹿にしてやろう
否定してやろうと思うならば
タッサディッテーワダンメーダササハダンマワーダーヌワーダーガーライヤンターナンガッチャンティ
彼にはこの世で 10箇所で非難されますよと
お釈迦様のやり方 これは偉大なる四重ですよと
たとえ神様にさえもこれは否定できんよと
これ設定しましたと もう終わりと最終
もう訂正なしと だから完璧ってことでしょうね
こんなこと言えるのはもうブッダ以外誰も言ってもないんですからね
それがお釈迦様は本当に学者という証拠なんですよ
もうまあ インドに昔いた
ちょっと頭のいいおじさんやっていう話じゃないんです
10箇所で非難されます
この世でお釈迦様 この世でと言うんですね
サンマディッティンチェーバワンガラハンティ
イエーチャミッチャディッティサマナブラフマナテーボーとプッジャテーボーとパーサンサ
そこでこの人が私が教えたことを非難しちゃうと
何を非難するかというと
正見を非難するんだよと
だからお釈迦様はわざと正見というのは宗教的な枠に入れてないんですよ
哲学 思考 智慧の枠に入れて食べてますよ
邪見は宗教の問題じゃなく
真理の世界であると 真理わからないことは邪見であるということだから
どうしようもないんですよ
それで私は客観的な 具体的な
正しいっていう見解を
真理を知ることが褒めているのに
この先生がそれを非難
非難しているんだから
いわゆる邪見を褒めているでしょうにと
正しく知らなくていいということを言っているんじゃないかと
そこで自己矛盾でやられているんだと
だから彼らを褒める人
この人を褒めるのはだらしない
サモンバラモンたちやと
いろんな邪見で汚い いろんな儀式
儀礼でもう身を染めている人々は素晴らしい
あなたは素晴らしいというだけですよと
サンカサッサンマーサンマサンカッパンチェーバワンガラハティ
そこで正しい思考非難しちゃうと
間違ってる思考を褒めてるでしょうに
だから頭おかしい連中では人気あるかもしれませんだけど
頭のいい人々からはもう追い出されますよと
だからブッダの正視は
非難した時点で自分が馬鹿にされているんです
正思惟だから正しい もういいに決まってるでしょうに
非難できませんということなんです
それで十カ条っていうのはこの十項目なんですよ
最後に九つ目はサンマニャーナでしょ
正恵ですね 正非難したら邪を褒めるんですかね
それ正解脱を非難して邪解脱褒めるんですかね
だから非難できんやと言った時点でもう馬鹿にされてるんだよと
そこでこの世で十か所でやられますよと
これすごい脅しでしょ
まだ当たり前でしょ 本当は脅してないでしょうに
ただ これはもう逆転できませんというところで言ってるだけで
全然脅し文句でもないんです
ただ もし誰かが非難しようと思ったら
無理ですね それは 喋った時点であ
間違った 喋らなかった方が良かったと思っちゃいますから
本人が そこでお釈迦様はある例えが出しますよ
エーピテービッケウェーアヘスンオッカラワッサバンニャー
このは日本学はできないし
パーリ語の私もあまりわかりません
これは昔のなんとかなんですね
で 注釈書を見るとなんとかもう解説あると思いますけど
当てにならないと思います
あのオッカラワッサバンニャーっていうのは何か喋る人々なんで
いわゆるもういい加減無茶苦茶
もうなんだらかんだらもう関係なく喋る人々やと思いますよ
アヘートワーダ 彼らはアヘート
原因は否定する アキリエワーダ
行為に結果否定する だからこの六子の外道の方々もこのグループに入りますね
行為に結果ありませんとか
ただ行為だけ 結果なしと人
刀でもって人を刺しちゃうと穴が空いただけで人殺したことになりませんし
それによって悪く悪結果になるわけでもありませんと
物体は物体を通りました
それで終わりと そういう風にこの行為を非難する
因果法則を非難する人々もいますよと
彼らがこのオッカラワッサバンニャーということで
ワッサっていうのはおそらく
雨だからね 雨のごとく喋るっていうことかな
わかりません 意味は  奥から地方のワッサとバンニャさんっていう
うん もしがするとそうかもしれません
これ大文字でやってますからね
そこから地方はありますけどね
ワッササンとバンニャさんかもしれません
この二人の例ですね そうすると彼らはアヘートワーダで
一人はアキリエワーダ
ナッティックワーダ もう皆無主義で
もう明確な皆無主義 しかし
彼らさえもこの私の四十項目だけは非難しようとしませんよと
そういうふうには何も言いませんよと
理由は非難されるんだからと言った時点で
ということで やっと経典が終わりました
十時になりました とにかく終わりたかっただけで
大変難しくて汗が出ます
こちらで八正道の正見について語った経典で
そうやって四十項目に分けて説明してあって
全くも非難否定できないという
もう断言的に語っています
それで我々には役に立つところは
この八正道でどんな項目をやるかな
やっぱり最初は正見 親分だからね
正見はまあ因果法則を理解して納得いくことですね
それなりに因果法則だよと
原因 例えば輪廻があるのかと言っちゃうと
わからないでしょ でも原因に結果があるんだから
人が死んだんだから 死んだことは原因でしょうし
結果が何かあるはずでしょうに
で 生きることは肉体を維持するだけじゃないんだからね
心で肉体 心が肉体を維持していたんだから
死んだということは 心がこの肉体を維持していないということでしょう
だったら何らかの結果が出るはずなんです
原因には結果は確実にあるというふうに
推測ででも正見に達しなくちゃいけないんです
それで正見があれば まあ他は全部親分だから呼び寄せてくれるんです
それをお釈迦様はおっしゃってるんです
正見さえあれば まあ他の仲間たちを
八正道の仲間たちを呼び寄せてくれる
それどちらにしても正正人と気づき
これはもう一緒にやらなくちゃいけないんですね
それは切り離すことはできない
ということで 勉強してください
どうもありがとうございます